[MUSIC PLAYING]
JONATHAN MCNULTY:
Trulia's mission
is to make it as
easy as possible
for you to find the
home of your dreams.
Trulia partners with MLSes
all across the United States
to bring in an immense amount of
data for available properties.
LAUREN HIRASHIMA:
Trulia's goal, really,
is to help you along in
your home search journey.
JONATHAN MCNULTY: Trulia has
had a tremendous run so far.
We actually see more than
half of our business now being
done on mobile applications.
So when we think about
products in the future,
when we think about how can
we be serving our users,
who are now really
engaging on mobile apps
more than anything
else, everything
we do is very much
mobile-centric.
Android provides a lot
of flexibility for us
to embed new and creative
features for our users.
LAUREN HIRASHIMA:
Android enabled
us to create a much
more stable app
and also to be able to
iterate a lot quicker.
Innovation is core
to Trulia's culture.
And we love that innovation
is core to Google's culture
as well.
JONATHAN MCNULTY:
Every quarter, we
have a week designated for
engineering product design
to really focus on what
they feel is important.
We've seen our push
notification system.
We've seen our mobile apps.
We've seen a lot of the
products that you see live today
on the site come out of
our innovation weeks.
LAUREN HIRASHIMA: So
after flipping the switch
on push notifications
on Android,
we saw an immediate impact.
And after learning
and iterating,
we saw a 30% increase
in engagement.
And engagement on
Android is two times that
of our other platforms.
At first, we saw a
number of complaints
come through when we were
sending too many notifications.
So we quickly
iterated and realized
that there is the sweet spot
for the number of notifications
you should send to
your users a day.
JONATHAN MCNULTY: We recently
launched nearby home alerts.
It actually uses a
geofencing technology
that Google's empowered us with.
LAUREN HIRASHIMA: Say
you're walking your dog
and you walk near a new listing.
You'll get an alert.
You can actually get
the alert on your watch,
see high-level details
about the property,
scroll through a few pictures,
and call the agent or email
the agent directly
from the watch.
Developing for Android
Wear was super easy.
It took one engineer
a couple of weeks
to have our app
live in Google Play.
We see more leads coming
from our Android platform
than any other platform.
We've been able to
partner with Google
on these new products
and new platforms
and deliver value
for both companies.